[Music]
thank you
let's try that again but with ninja
stars
hey why do we pick a fruit shaped
exactly like my head just stop talking
you're ruining my concentration you're
fine chill he's gonna die
wait did you hear that what was that
well not that we can do you guys want to
grab pizza
what the heck are those things those are
like little Shreks to me
yeah
we've prepared our whole life for this
Hannah
oh my God
what happened is
so you were baby turtles who made
contact with mystery goo we prefer the
term ooze but yeah it's like more like
it's just it rolls off the tongue better
yeah
it's nice right
[Music]
where am I
oh fresh meat for the grinder pay him no
heat
but he is there's gotta be a way out of
here there's no escape the only hope is
the story really from Death whoa well
you've got to be kidding me
my Army Koopas
whatever those things are oh
we will destroy the Mushroom Kingdom
Bowser is coming I'm not afraid I'll do
anything for my brother we're going to
save him
you asked for it this is fun
here we
go
and this
[Music]
thank you
I can hear you being quiet mom
I am
hope I didn't ice your game man
no one my age says those words in that
order
it's just hard to see my little man not
be my little boy all the time
here
you know for years I've been taking care
of this little boy
making sure he is loved
love but he feels like he belongs
wherever he wants to be
he wants to go out into the world and do
great big things
not bad kid
and what I worry about most
I love you Moss
is they won't look out for you like us
want to get out of here
wherever you go from here you have to
promise to take care of that little boy
for me
or he never forgets where he came from
[Music]
and
he never doubts that he's loved
and he never lets anyone
tell him that he doesn't belong there
you gotta promise miles
I promise
[Music]
who do you think you are really
we are supposed
we are
[Music]
thank you
five days
[Music]
and when she go I'll never know
sorry
I'm Wade I'm Amber
[Music]
tell me
how did you come to Neverland
Lost Boys every last one of us
you're not all boys so
what is this place it's home
Peter found it just like you found all
of us
hitting someone else
what'd she say boys you're a different
Adventure
it's very far away it's closer than you
think
is it that you're afraid of my love
perhaps I don't want to grow up
hold the past in your heart but where
you go from here it's up to you
Wendy Moira Angela darling
where is Peter Pan
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
wish I could be
please
heart of that world
[Music]
for almost 20 years I'll be moving these
antennae around in vain to make contact
with outer space as soon as you arrived
the signal started coming
I believe that you
are a human
and antenna
human antenna what is your status over
I got a dog
[Music]
what's your name my name is Obama oh
crap
oh crap where are we going now little
darling come on follow me oh no this is
not happening I think it's best if we go
to Wild Splat Walt this is Obama
uh no my name's actually Brittany
Brittany
Walt she crashed with her spaceship and
a man came and took it and now she can't
get home oh my word that's Robert is he
a bad man no no he's not a bad guy but
his brother is we will finally know the
answer does life exist in outer space
and more importantly can it be stuffed
we need to get to the spaceship little
antenna before he does we gotta hurry I
love that kind of enthusiasm let's go
thank you
here we go let's see what to do about
this
hang on Teddy
I can see the whole world wonderful
I promise you we'll get your spaceship
tomorrow huh
would you like a cup sure thanks maybe
just half a cup
[Music]
[Applause]
divinity
Brothers
[Music]
between
them
[Music]
[Laughter]
control
s
[Music]
voila
I've always wanted to be a heroine
[Music]
a hero is a human Patty not a little
mouse like you oh you missed you Zeus
our gratitude it's awesome certainly
deserve
I'll give you Southern days to make a
statue of me that there's beautiful as
my brothers come on they're all counting
on us
all I have
me I wonder when it's like going through
rough weather on a boat add more
lightning
yeah feeling a bit seasick don't have my
ceilings yet
of mucus is in our hands
[Music]
family and we can conquer anything
beneath the world of the living lies the
land of the living dead today my
daughter the Phoenix will choose your
future husband
in seven days you shall wear the
princess marry we've never even met he
in I have to marry a guy who's only
talented riding around in a circle if
anything happens to this ring
they will cut out your tongue and pluck
out your eyes kind of brings new meaning
to the expression Love is Blind
this ring is going
where nobody else can get to him
[Music]
on the other side of this door
like a doorway to a world of living
mummies
but you look at that a royal wedding
ring
this could only be the work of livings
this will be the jewel of my new
exhibition the only way to get it back
is to go to the world of the living
you're not alone you have a team
what ice is this I've never seen
anything like it
[Music]
oh
god of the son God of Life Light our
path please kindly finish your shopping
we have and proceed towards the exit oh
thank you magnificent Rob
we are gathered here today to say
goodbye to boots
went down to your last life
you need to retire
[Music]
oh
brother cats sister kitties meet your
new roommates well
I supposed to be a furious hero a legend
this is a person party that's your party
so this is where dignity Goes To Die the
year start coming and they don't stop
coming
your Puss in Boots let's talk
I don't speak Spanish either
you're funny uh what's your story my
story
what are we looking at can't have nine
lives
now I am on my last life oh no
legendary
waiting to be grounded
I need your help is the great posing
Goods asking for help well you see yeah
okay please that way you get me my lives
back okay okay awesome face I won't make
your bag but first
what what what's funny nothing should be
funny
everyone is looking for the Wishing Star
I'm going to wish everything to be just
right
you will find your reward does not come
easily Puss in Boots Goldie Bears all
right
[Music]
when you only have one life that's what
makes it special go get him tiger hey
take it easy
[Music]
the Wishing Star is in the dark Forest
we step through as one ready one two
after you wait what
dog still alive let's go find out
Legion Academy if you wanted you could
train here think of them as the Futures
Justice League
great to meet you I'm monel this is the
rest of the academy trainees
we are the front lines administering
Justice and preventing War
cousin is a problem she failed to
control her powers Brainiac
s are a threat I don't like what you're
implying
we still have no idea where the rest of
the Legion is
so let's go be heroes
[Music]
the original fairy tales are all the
same
the princess the hero but this story
about me meow
our next Target is this way okay what
have you noticed there's no food that is
odd for a market Town
it smells doesn't it smells like a a
mystery
[Music]
the food in the town but continues to
disappear
for us you wanted to see us there are
new rats in town I can feel it catch
them and bring them to me yeah yes sir
remember this is a new town There's
bound to be new tracks
I know just what we must do next solve
the mystery of our town ready
your savior has arrived
hey everyone look for the entrance to
the secret passage
Keith are you all right yeah I'm all
right because I landed on my head no
wonder we didn't see it
no I have a thing for rats it's not cool
to pick on the little guy fighting for a
life
is please follow me here I come
to me
then feel my pain
if my head fits the rest will follow
[Music]
the amazing Maurice it's really not your
average fairy tale don't worry a cat
always lands on its feet
[Music]
amazing Maurice
I'm Sophie I'm Tim for a young man
passing it about music there's no
greater place to be than Mozart's
what's your instrument
show me what you got
enough
where did you go last night
do you believe me do I believe that
o'clock in the school is a portal into a
Mozart's brother Masterpiece no
[Music]
what are you doing back there I have no
idea where I am
the young friends
back my beloved daughter
oh I'm not sure about the whole Peril of
Death part you shouldn't take a risk if
you're gonna figure out what it is
you're missing
pissing me now to rescue you
[Music]
Doom
the great Doom is coming
[Music]
sins of the father are heaped upon the
sun
you have no clue the power this book
possesses
mean to do this city harm
before it can be truly saved Gotham
must be burned to the ground
Talking Dead folks reptile plagues it's
not natural
it's a cult
long ties together
now I can't pretend to know exactly what
I'm about to face but I do know
but I must stop it
we need to give this city purpose and
honor the damnation for it
what's happening to you
what needs it to happen
whose way must die
become this city savior
[Music]
hello Bruce you can't be
there Comes A Time in every child's life
when they have a fervent desire to go
somewhere dig for Hidden Treasure there
it is
Tom and Mr Twain would never have made
it easy as power for just anyone to find
to whomever should find this my story
lives forever in the pages of Tom Sawyer
they discover pirate's gold listen this
could be like our one time to do
something great let's find Tom Sawyer's
gold all right the quest is on you guys
have gotten closer than anyone ever has
with this I knew it how would you like
to become really rich plenty of folk are
gone searching for Tom Sawyer's gold
pirate gold in one you love Adventure if
we do this and we are back
home it's only accessible through the
Bayou solve the puzzles they're laid and
look within to see crack the code
discover an adventure let's move
Greater Than Fiction the map we're done
I'm not gonna let that happen
Fame and boy look Within
and you'll see
Patrick muldu there ain't gonna be no
stopping me this time I should have
known that you were behind this with
Joey Lauren Adams
this is so cool we're gonna see this
through we're gonna keep doing this
we've gone and done what no one's ever
done before
the Tom Sawyer's gold thanks Mario
this there's one or two things I haven't
quite told you about yet
[Music]
ah dude I barely recognize you freshman
Chang is no more tank 2.0 is here baby
Kobe
you seem pretty into basketball so why
aren't you out there then hey Christy
but it's for you
okay yeah you can dunk so can a lot of
people you can't yeah I could if I tried
[Applause]
hey Pat on the night of the last home
football game I bet you I will dunk on
that hoop what are you putting down I
have a first edition Charizard Pokemon
card shadowless yeah or three grand
so what's the plan this guy she's gonna
teach me how to dunk
hey Andre and you said you were a
basketball coach you said you were six
foot
give chain can't dunk by our last
football game he's gonna have to move to
another school yikes I'll do anything
you asked me to do we're gonna do a
whole series on you
yo I'm changing I'm gonna dunking all my
haters yeah yeah oh you were serious
you're home away from home no wait cause
you in the bar
kid from the main
I have 10 bucks on you dunking oh hey
don't worry my man's got this I didn't
seemed like this before I thought he'd
quit after a week use that chord chain
but he didn't
kept going
about you dude it was five eight he's
inspirational
let's go why do you want to dunk so bad
is it really about this bet with Matt
like a dunk it would be proof that I
could be
more than who I am
on top of the game
Y'all Gonna remember the name
[Laughter]
[Music]